how are you doing Harrison I'm doing
well always really appreciate it
what were you able to see out of
Garoppolo that you were able to exploit
that other defenses have had trouble
doing Harrison you know it always starts
with with our guys up front with our
pass rush and they you know they make
things a little easier for us on the
back end when they're getting pressure
and and getting a quarterback kind of
off the spot and getting them
uncomfortable so you know that's where
we start and then we just try to cover
on the back end and take take advantage
of the opportunities when they arise
that's very Bella checking so just do
your job it's basically what you're
saying right there yeah I mean pretty
much you know we you know we've we play
us a lot of passions and we study
throughout the weekend and just lay it
on the line on Sundays but you know as a
defensive back you know when we get when
we get an interception or something and
people get all excited I always like to
look at the D line because they normally
effected that play and whether people
realize I mean there is an eye in
Harrison and Smith for you to say
something like that it's it's a great
team mentality right there so let me ask
you this Harrison Smith who do you think
you see under center in Lambeau Field on
Sunday Aaron Rodgers or Deshawn Kaiser
um I mean I buy I watched the game
Sunday night and and I saw you know
obviously Rodgers came back and you know
led him to an an amazing comeback so you
know he's capable of doing incredible
things on the field so I wouldn't be
surprised to see him out there so we
just got to get ready for both I guess
yeah I guess so but so you're you're
expecting to see 12 when it's all said
and done oh I mean yeah he came back in
that game so that's that's what I would
expect that I mean we'll see what you
know we haven't really been able to get
our meetings and yet until tomorrow so
we'll see what the coaches are thinking
what does this game mean week to you
know hey I hate to sound belly checking
again but uh you know it's the next game
since the biggest you are not
to do one game at a time with me
Harrison Smith I mean that that's
literally all you can do you can't do
more well it's not just any game I mean
this is Aaron Rodgers this is the
Packers this is the Vikings this is the
NFC North hold on a minute let me let me
continue setting this up this is this is
the guy that Anthony Barr knocked out
I'm telling you there do you know what I
mean yes yes yeah I mean I'm sure that
that storyline will get a lot of hype
you know especially with the new rule
changes and everything you know it is
the division games no matter who it is
you know they they are big especially
when it comes down to the end of the
season and people are positioned for
playoffs so you know we we understand
that we also understand you know the
pride that the Vikings fans have you
know with this kind of border battle so
we we understand that and and you know
ramp it up but it's not you know it's
not make or break right now but we will
definitely you know try Barry do you
mention that rule that you mentioned
about not allowing to put your body
weight on a quarterback when you sack
them do you ever talk about that with
Anthony bar in the locker room oh no we
don't I mean we we honestly we do talk
about trying I have to play within the
rules a lot just because it's hard to
always sack the quarterback and then
slide to the side of him it's just it's
hard to do in real time so we talk about
those things but you know I think he
took a lot of heat on on social media
and stuff last year from from people so
it's more of a joke than anything for us
so what are those conversations like
when you're a defender talking with your
coaches or amongst your your colleagues
about the rules about lowering your head
about moving your body to the side about
doing all this and trying yet to play as
instinctively as you possibly can
because that's in many ways what got you
to this position to play in the National
Football League
Harrison Smith yeah I think um you know
normally these conversations start with
divas a players kind of complaining and
saying how hard it is and stuff like
that that doesn't help us to complain
about it like they made the rules so now
I have to figure out how to play within
it so we we talk about just
you know lowering kind of lowering your
target instead of launching and aiming
you know just kind of recklessly
consciously thinking about when you're
making a break about already lower than
that target keeping your head up wrap it
up as long as you're trying to do those
things you know maybe an accident here
here there happens it's that's a nature
of the game but it's if you're trying to
do them that's that's you know if you
have that intent beforehand it normally
translate translates to you know cleaner
tackles within the rules of the game
today
Viking safety pro-bowl safety Harrison
Smith couple more minutes left with him
here on the Rich Eisen show last night
Monday Night Football Darren Lee of the
Jets picked off Matthew Stafford twice
the Jets really laid it on your NFC
North colleagues in the Honolulu blue he
said after the game that the Jets knew
the hand signals and knew what players
were being called before the snap is
that something that makes sense to you
yeah I saw that report you know every
now and then you'll maybe see a hand
signal or something but to know I think
to know every play that's coming
beforehand I think that's probably
probably a little overblown I don't know
I'm not sitting in those meetings but
you know you try to watch as much film
as you can and and pick up on formations
and down at distances then sometimes you
know you're prepared and they run
exactly what you think and then other
times they're on has things you've never
seen before seen before you know because
because everyone's good in this league
players the coaches and everyone adapts
so you know if that's what he says
that's great you know normally I think
it's a little harder than that yeah it's
about two so I mean you play the lines
twice though I mean so it's not just
watching film it's it's a team that you
you know better than most is that is
that something you've been able to pick
up just a hand signal and you see it and
you know what's coming Harrison
specifically with the Lions yes sir no I
mean I can't I can't second that
just because you know maybe maybe I'm
not as good at studying film I don't
know
yeah you know if they did that's awesome
wrong I hope we can do the same well
what can you pick up in film serials
that walk me through that a little bit
it kind of depends on how they're kind
of spliced up and you know sometimes you
can see see a little bit pre-snap stuff
sometimes you can't you know normally
just like just like they watch our film
you know kind of what are our favorite
things that we do we try to try to do
that with them and you know personnel
groupings and downs and distances and
scenarios of the game you just try to
kind of simulate those things in your
mind and and the scenarios you could be
faced with once the game comes around
well we've gone this long and I haven't
even mentioned the name Kirk Cousins so
I might as well do it here then the
notion outside of your stadium locker
room is that same team essentially a
couple more improvements Kirk Cousins in
here just roll the footballs out you
guys have a Super Bowl team how do you
respond to that that I I think Jim would
be pretty upset with me if I I agree
tolling the footballs out he actually
says that term a lot about how was he
going to show up and all the footballs
out yeah you know if he thinks we're
getting a little lackadaisical or
something so we you know we definitely
don't have that that feeling in the
locker room or in the building and no
matter who's on our team or how much
hype we're getting outside the building
know that stuff that we don't let affect
us we just focus on inside the building
what we're doing you know making plays
when they when they arise and that's
offense defense special teams and and
Kirk has come in and and you know
already made a tremendous a tremendous
impact for our offense but also for our
defense working against Dillon practice
has been awesome and it's helped us out
a lot how so
just because he's such a good player and
he's very quick to learn about the
things that we're doing and how we're
trying to attack him so he tries you
know to counter that so it just keeps us
honest and it really gives us good
competition throughout the week all
right tell me about the big tackles
campaign that you're doing for a third
season in a row Harrison Smith yeah big
brothers big
sisters and twin cities you know try to
raise money for them for mentorship for
the youth here and you know I donate for
every tackle that I'm making and if you
want to match it
ww big tackles org you know help me out
help Big Brothers Big Sisters out it's a
great organization so doing good things
last year raised over forty one thousand
dollars you can go also to pledget org
slash Harrison Smith 2018 to to get on
board with all this Harrison normally
I'd like to talk college football with
my NFL guests but we're out of time I
think I know why well no no I be deep
I'm just I'm honestly I mean we just
only have mere seconds left I mean it's
really good it's real I mean are you are
you accusing trying to dodge something
you're not calling back into my shell
before next year's oh you're saying I'm
just saying when you want to talk about
college football maybe it'll be a little
better for you come come this time next
year okay no Tyler Eifert said he was
gonna send me gear cuz I bet him on this
contest he said he was gonna send me
gear cuz I have to wear gear on my
Twitter avatar for just what one day is
that what it was for just a single day
maybe I think that's what it was he has
yet to do it Harrison so for my for my
for my hat size you're talking about
head size shirt size okay
look through the whole outfit here oh I
don't know if I agree like don't send me
Zubaz I mean they're putting me up in
Ohio state gear that I had to wear over
a couple years ago
salmon airs every year yeah on my hat
size I mean I'm a size large and shirt
hat size I don't know but I'm an on-air
host so it's probably large you know
okay extra large good to chat with you
Harrison will chat with you soon they
grab me on you always you bet big
tackles org for Harrison Smith who's at
Harry har ri Smith 22 on Twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience
you